[Música]
Reino Unido da su último adiós a Isabel
II luego de una maratónica jornada y más
de 10 días de duelo nacional el cuerpo
de la monarca yace en la bóveda de la
capilla de Saint George del castillo de
Windsor este lunes es líderes mundiales
de miles y miles de británicos y la
familia real rindieron su tributo a la
monarca más longeva de Reino Unido
Rusia calificó de mentira los
señalamientos de Ucrania sobre los más
de 400 cuerpos encontrados en una fosa
común en icim el presidente bolodimir
celenski denunció evidencias de tortura
y hoy culpó a tropas del kremlin de un
nuevo ataque contra una central nuclear
existen las protestas en Irán luego del
fallecimiento de masa mini tras ser
detenida por mal uso del jillab tanto la
capital Teherán como la región del
kurdistán iraní de dónde era la joven
fallecida fueron los principales focos
de protesta este lunes Tenemos reporte
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 y Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos abrimos este Informativo en
Reino Unido el féretro de Isabel II ya
reposa en la bóveda Real de la capilla
de San George luego del servicio
religioso en el que cerca de 800
personas presentaron sus respetos a la
monarca previamente en Londres Se llevó
a cabo el funeral de estado en la abadía
de Westminster donde líderes mundiales y
miles de británicos dieron el último
adiós a la reina fallecida
fue el último adiós a la reina después
de cuatro días en los que miles de
personas pasaron frente al ataúd de
Isabel II en la parte más antigua del
parlamento británico el féretro de la
monarca fue transportado por 142 Marines
hacia la abadía de Westminster mientras
detrás caminaba en el Rey Carlos III y
sus hermanos La princesa Ana y Los
Príncipes Andrés y Eduardo también fue
escoltado por William y Harry nietos de
Isabel II
la ceremonia fúnebre la primera de un
monarca británico en ser transmitida se
consagró como el primer funeral de
estado desde el de Winston Churchill en
Su difunta Majestad declararon una
transmisión de su cumpleaños 21 que se
dedicaría a toda su vida a servir a la
nación y a la mancomunidad de Naciones
rara vez se ha cumplido también una
promesa así cerca de 500 de los 2000
invitados eran líderes internacionales
los ex primeros ministros de Reino Unido
David Cameron Teresa May Boris Johnson y
la actual Premier leathstroke también
estuvieron presentes la ceremonia de un
poco más de 50 minutos tuvo lecturas y
cánticos religiosos y se escuchó el
himno Dios salve al rey recién
modificado para el nuevo monarca Carlos
III
[Música]
Poco después los restos de la Reina
Isabel pasaron en una histórica
procesión por las calles del centro de
Londres hacia el arco de Wellington muy
cercano al palacio de buckingham más de
6.000 soldados participaron en el
recorrido una vez en el coche fúnebre el
ataúd tomo rumbo a la capilla de San
George en el castillo de Windsor A las
afueras de Londres lugar donde cerca de
800 personas presentaron por última
ocasión sus respetos a Isabel II allí
finalmente la monarca más longeva de
Reino Unido descansará junto a la tumba
de su padre el rey Jorge vi Isabel la
reina madre y su esposo Felipe El Duque
de edimburgo
actualizamos las noticias sobre la
guerra en Ucrania las autoridades
prorusas de doniesc denunciaron este
lunes un ataque ucraniano contra la
ciudad según estas autoridades fueron 13
los muertos causados por este ataque
contra una plaza en el distrito de
alcalde de la ciudad aclaró que nueve
proyectiles de 155 milímetros habrían
impactado contra el lugar
seguimos en Ucrania el presidente
bolodimir celensky publicó imágenes de
un supuesto ataque ruso a otra planta
nuclear distinta a la de zaporilla
mientras que Rusia se refirió a las
acusaciones de tortura que hizo kiev a
Moscú por el hallazgo de más de 400
tumbas en edición una de las ciudades
recuperadas por las tropas ucranianas en
la región de jarquif El informes de Juan
Pablo lucumí
un nuevo ataque a otra planta nuclear
ucraniana
bolodimirselensky compartió vía Telegram
imágenes de una explosión a tan solo 300
metros de los reactores de la planta
pide nocrains según el presidente de
Ucrania el bombardeo fue perpetrado por
las tropas rusas y daño los edificios de
la central Los Invasores querían
disparar nuevamente pero olvidaron lo
que es una planta de energía nuclear
Rusia pone en peligro al mundo entero
tenemos que detener esto antes de que
sea demasiado tarde
la planta más grande de Europa ubicada
en sapurilla fue cerrada a principios de
este mes debido a bombardeos cercanos a
la zona ataques que Ucrania y Rusia se
adjudicaron mutuamente entre tanto otro
señalamientos llegan a Rusia por parte
de Ucrania este domingo fueron exhumados
más cuerpos de las 440 tumbas de la fosa
común que se les que reportó a las
afueras de la ciudad de siumo el
presidente de Ucrania dijo que había
evidencias de tortura y comparó la
situación con lo sucedido en bucha en
abril cuando se encontraron cosas
comunes en la periferia de la capital
kiev y pidió que el hecho sea marcado
como crimen de guerra por parte de la
comunidad internacional y aunque aún no
se han establecido las causas de las
muertes este lunes se conoció la primera
reacción oficial rusa a las acusaciones
ucranianas el kremlin calificó los
señalamientos de mentira y aseguró que
se encargará de contar la verdadera
historia
es el mismo guión que embucha todo se
desarrolla por el mismo guión es una
mentira la misión de Derechos Humanos
que la ONU tiene desplegada en Ucrania
anunció que tenía previsto verificar los
hallazgos sobre el terreno Y la
presidencia de la Unión Europea pidió
Establecer un tribunal especial para
juzgar los supuestos crímenes
persisten las protestas en Irán luego
del fallecimiento de la joven masa mini
las manifestaciones de este lunes fueron
especialmente nutridas en la provincia
del kurdistán iraní de donde era
originaria la joven fallecida pero
también enteerán más a mini murió el
pasado viernes producto de un infarto
luego de que fuera detenida por la el
día de la moral por no llevar el jillab
de manera correcta nuestra corresponsal
en Irán Catalina Gómez Ángel nos amplía
ninguna declaración o acción del
gobierno iraní parece apaciguar los
ánimos de la gran parte de la población
indignada por la muerte de esa joven de
22 años maxa el pasado martes hoy el
jefe de la policía de Teherán aseguró
que ninguno de los integrantes del
cuerpo policial había abusado
violentamente de esta joven y el
presidente Ibrahim Rey sí llamó hace un
par de días a su familia diciendo que
llevarían a cabo una investigación hasta
el final y que ella también era su hija
aún así las protestas continúan esto
especialmente en las áreas kurdas en el
noroccidente del país maxa es de una
población llamada zaguezi allí
comenzaron las protestas desde el mismo
día de su entierro cientos de personas
cantaron eslogans muchas de ellos decían
muerte al dictador refiriéndose al
supremo de la Revolución
y otras protestas siguieron en el día de
hoy una huelga general en el comercio de
esas grandes ciudades cudas y siguen
habiendo protestas una organización de
Derechos Humanos asegura que en esa
región ha habido por lo menos 38
personas heridas pero las protestas
también se han extendido en verano y
había una represión violenta de una
manifestación también convocada en el
centro de Teherán los vídeos muestran
como la policía atacó con violencia
muchas mujeres que se quitaron el velo y
en las grandes universidades de la
ciudad también hubo protestas esta
mañana hablamos ahora de noticias
relacionadas con Afganistán este lunes
el gobierno liderado por los talibanes y
Estados Unidos llevaron a cabo un
intercambio de prisioneros Washington
liberó al líder tribal allí vasir North
Side encarcelado durante 17 años por
tráfico de drogas a cambio del ingeniero
estadounidense Marc frerix retenido
desde febrero de 2020 en kabul Alba
Santana tiene los detalles
acercamiento entre Estados Unidos y
Afganistán tras un intercambio de
prisioneros el líder tribal
hajibachirnos Ray volvió a kabul donde
lo recibieron con los brazos abiertos
tras décadas encerrado en Estados Unidos
todo a cambio de la liberación del
ingeniero estadounidense Marc retenido
en Afganistán desde febrero de 2020
donde trabajaba en proyectos de
desarrollo
hoy a las 10 de la mañana el ciudadano
estadounidense Mark freerich que estaba
encarcelado en Afganistán ha sido
intercambiado tras una larga negociación
con los estadounidenses
había estado encarcelado desde 2005 por
supuesto contrabando de drogas y fue uno
de los últimos prisioneros afganos en la
prisión de alta seguridad de guantánamo
ahora tras su Liberación los talibanes
han interpretado esta negociación como
un posible acercamiento con Estados
Unidos
creo que si Dios quiere mi intercambio
crearía una ruta de paz entre Afganistán
y Estados Unidos
por su parte el gobierno de Joe biden ha
estado bajo la presión de los familiares
de las personas encarceladas en el
extranjero Y ha prometido intensificar
los esfuerzos por liberarlos
se va la negociaciones que condujeron a
la libertad de Mark a una resolución
exitosa requirió decisiones difíciles
que no tomé a la ligera nuestra
prioridad ahora es asegurarnos de quemar
que reciba un regreso saludable y seguro
y se le dé el espacio y el tiempo que
necesita para volver a la sociedad a
pesar de haber estado recluido en
guantánamo las autoridades
estadounidenses aseguraron que la
liberación de norkshire no supone ningún
riesgo para los estadounidenses
nuevo capítulo en la tensión entre China
y Estados Unidos por Taiwán el gobierno
de Beijing calificó como una grave
vulneración las recientes declaraciones
del presidente Joe biden sobre la isla
en una entrevista a medios locales
vaiden aseguró que su país defendería a
taipei ante una eventual intervención
china el portavoz del Ministerio de
relaciones exteriores chino aseguró que
estas palabras envían una mala señal más
detalles en el siguiente informe
es una palabra que podría tener fuertes
consecuencias así que a diferencia de
Ucrania Señor las fuerzas
estadounidenses los hombres y las
mujeres estadounidenses defenderían a
Taiwán en caso de una invasión china así
al mencionar el apoyo militar directo de
Washington rompe con la doctrina
estadounidense hacia Taiwán denominada
ambigüedad estratégica indica que
Washington ayudará a la isla a
defenderse en caso de Invasión china
pero sin especificar si esto implicaría
la intervención militar de Estados
Unidos Beijing no esperó para contestar
este lunes acusó a Estados Unidos de
violar su compromiso de no apoyar la
independencia de Taiwán y de amenazar la
estabilidad del estrecho
nunca toleraremos Ninguna actividad que
tenga como objetivo dividir el país y
nos reservamos el derecho de tomar todas
las medidas necesarias Nadie debe
subestimar la resuelta determinación del
pueblo chino y su fuerte capacidad para
defender la soberanía nacional y la
integridad territorial no se enfrentan a
los 1400 millones de chinos Estados
Unidos reconoció en 1979 la política de
una sola china Lo que incluía a Taiwán
pero a principios de agosto la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes Nancy pelosi visitó La
Isla lo que enfureció a Beijing en
represalia China llevó a cabo enormes
ejercicios militares acercándose a pocos
kilómetros de la costa taiwanesa unas
tensiones que resurgen en momentos en
que el senado de Estados Unidos estudia
entregar ayuda militar a Taiwán más de
4.000 millones de dólares en defensa
para los próximos años
se cumple un año desde la erupción del
volcán en La Isla canaria de la palma
que mantuvo en vilo a toda España
durante 85 días el fenómeno dejó más de
7000 evacuados y 3.000 edificaciones
destruidas a pesar de las millonarias
ayudas aún hay cientos de personas que
no han podido regresar a sus casas y
muchos vecinos denuncian la pésima
gestión nuestra corresponsal en Madrid
Marina Colorado no se amplía
todo el mundo coincide en esto aún queda
mucho camino por recorrer en la
recuperación de la isla de la palma que
hace un año vio como la tierra se abría
por la erupción del volcán tajogaite un
nombre que no es oficial pero que fue
elegido por los vecinos de La Isla para
bautizar a la nueva montaña en su
paisaje 365 días en los que los
gobiernos de España y Canarias han
invertido cerca de 600 millones de euros
casi la mitad dedicados a vivienda y
alojamiento Y es que más de mil hogares
Fueron destruidos por lo que muchas
familias tuvieron que irse a hoteles u a
otras viviendas secundarias o temporales
sin embargo hasta ahora solo se han
entregado 139 casas Aunque el gobierno
asegura que pronto habrá 170 más
disponibles además hay unas 1700
personas que a pesar de que sus hogares
Y negocios están intactos no pueden
regresar a ellos ya que se encuentran en
Puerto naos y la bombilla donde las
emanaciones de gases tóxicas son tan
elevadas que según los técnicos no son
compatibles con la vida pese a las
nuevas ayudas para el alquiler
anunciadas hoy por el gobierno y a
millones de euros dedicados para la
compra de muebles y ropa los más de
20.000 afectados denuncian que la
gestión ha sido pésima y que la falta de
coordinación ha hecho que la ayuda no
llegue por igual a los palmeros
caracterizan al gobierno por su
complacencia su silencio y por el olvido
según ellos para que la reconstrucción
de La Isla sea plena las ayudas tendrían
que duplicarse hasta alcanzar los mil
millones de euros
México conmemoró el doble aniversario de
los terremotos de 1985 y 2017 el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
encabezó la ceremonia en la que se
recordó a las víctimas que dejaron los
sismos en 2017 un terremoto de magnitud
7,1 dejó cerca de 369 muertos de los
cuales 228 fueron en Ciudad de México
mientras que lo ocurrido en 1985 cobró
la vida según estimaciones de entre
cerca de 3.192 y 20.000 personas en todo
el país
hasta aquí este repaso informativo sigan
conectados a France 24
[Música]